the world renowned soprano began gracing
the world's greatest opera houses and
concert halls decades ago she is a
four-time Grammy winner who earned the
National Medal of Arts back in 2012
Fleming is the first classical artist to
sing the national anthem at a Super Bowl
I remember that and now she's making her
Broadway musical debut and Rodgers and
Hammerstein's carousel
[Music]
well playing Nettie fowler fleming sings
you'll never walk alone and what's known
as richard rogers favorite musical we
welcome renee fleming to the table in
studio 57 hello Thank You Gail
thank you so it's your first Broadway
musical this is something you've always
wanted to do well not really you know it
was an aspiring to take on new worlds it
came out of the blue and it just the
time he seemed to write another food
from warehouse I'm Scott Rudin from the
producer and Jack O'Brien the director
and Andy Einhorn and they called you up
and said what they said how would you
love to do this would you consider doing
this we would love to have you and I I
just thought you know that would I'm the
kind of person that if I said no I would
always wonder what if yeah so I thought
yeah I'm gonna try this and how's the
transition been from opera to Broadway
well it's been you know I knew it was
gonna be a shock to my system because a
chose a week is an enormous challenge
and we're kind of you know we're sort of
the powerlifters of singing we're not
amplified in classical music so we can't
do more than maximum three a week
because we need the downtime so this I
thought how am I gonna do this
but amplification makes it much easier
and what does that mean amplification so
that when you have a microphone instead
of the body doing the power the
technology does the power for us so you
can afford not quite to get so tired as
how does that for somebody I mean how
different is that in terms of singing is
that a small change or is that a real
big change oh it's huge its massive I
mean because you know if you go to the
stage of the Metropolitan Opera for
instance which seats 4,000 people
there's no microphone we thought about
that we're like ventriloquist you know
it's really different and technically
speaking how we sing did that take a
little bit of an adjustment on stage I'm
still adjusting yeah I'm still adjusting
and what about carousel is such a famous
work well you'll never walk alone yes
and whatever you like to take on
something that it has that much history
and it's that well-known well they've
sung the piece for a long time I also
sang it at the 9/11 memorial and I let
people love the song I mean it's it's
one of those iconic pieces like Amazing
Grace and Leonard Cohen's Hallelujah
everyone loves but to do it in the
context of the piece it's different it's
so emotional it's so much more about
that incredibly tragic moment and you
were saying that this time when you're
doing this you don't have to travel that
you get to be home I know it's that like
you know you could take a residency in
Vegas you don't have to travel so you
are home I'm home I learn how to cook
I'm you know biking everywhere and
having a blast I just it's really a
pleasure to sleep in your own bed
cleaning I'm cleaning out closets for
the first time in a long time you are
physically cleaning out clothes it's
very exciting somebody has the most
beautiful gowns yes I know I have to ask
you about this partnership that the
Kennedy Center and the National
Institute of Health are doing about the
connection between the music and the
brain I'm fascinated what have you
learned so far oh it's unbelievable well
first of all I mean to be a consultant
for the Kennedy Center it's a privilege
and to connect with the other major
institution one of them in Washington
it's even better but what we've
discovered and what I've learned is that
the brain and music are so intertwined
and music has a very powerful effect on
the brain so it affects childhood
development it makes kids into better
students it has a lot to do with the
amount of therapy they can be given to
people who've had traumatic brain injury
stroke Alzheimer's autism so many
treatments that are music based yeah and
imagine a pain relief for instance and
thinking about isolation and loneliness
is one of the really tragic epidemics in
our country music and a shared community
experience of the performing arts can be
very helpful in that and the other thing
is research so modern history is short
compared to all of the history of man
and music cave paintings all of these
things kept us together
Renee rumor is you're the commencement
speaker for Northwestern coming up is
someone in the class are very excited
about you coming what's your overall
message oh yeah listen I I you know what
I have too many messages so I'm gonna
try and narrow it down and pick and
choose a little bit but I do want to
focus a little bit on this community
about keeping your community healthy
whether it's at home
the smaller group that you're in the
city that you're in and thinking really
micro instead of macro now you have the
most beautiful voice in the world we're
so through thank you congratulations on
carousel